joining me today
so thank you very much for joining i
hope that you'll
get a lot out of this presentation today
uh
because i'm going to be talking about
developing and also evaluating secure
open source
software so very quickly here's my
outline
i'm just going to jump right into it so
quick quick background because i found
that some people
don't know about some of these things
first of all i'm talking about open
source software
what is open source software or that
software license to users with certain
freedoms run it
for any purpose modify study freely
redistribute either the original or a
modified version
uh there's a full definition in the open
source definition
and there's a lot of common licenses
like the mit apache 2o
lgpl gpl if you're talking about
software and it's not open source offer
typically it's called closed source or
proprietary software um
although it's not as focused it's not
the focus of this talk
it's important to understand the open
source software at least under u.s
law is a kind of commercial software
it's licensed to the general public
and automatically that makes it
commercial software that that's actually
pretty important if you ever have to
interact with some organizations like
the
uh us government um open source software
licenses
uh enable worldwide collaborative
development of software and that can
have many positive benefits
including positive benefits for security
open source software is critically
important today here's some figures you
know
almost all 98 of code bases
contain open source software uh when
synopsis looked
into programs they found that even if
the software as a whole
was proprietary when you average things
out 70 of code bases were
internally open source and there's more
and more and more
open source components within
applications
and that growth continues
now so i've talked about open source
offer now let me talk about security the
reality today is that all software is
under attack
open source closed source doesn't matter
they're all under attack and here's just
some of the many many
examples uh that i hope i hope i don't
have to strongly prove this
uh in this context but just you know
it's not just open source it's not just
closed source it's
all software it's under attack both
directly
attackers trying to exploit this
vulnerabilities and via supply chain
attacks where attackers try to subvert
the process of getting the software to
the its eventual users
if you only can look at one slide today
here's your slide now i'm kind of hoping
you'll see some other material i'm going
to talk about but
if you are developing open source
software i'm hoping that you
understand you need to make it secure as
one of those
important categories well how do i do
that well here's
kind of a top list of things that you
need to be doing
number one and in many ways the most
important
learn how to do it the sad state of
affairs today
is that most colleges most universities
that teach how to develop software
um don't teach how to develop
secure software i think that's terrible
i think that's awful
but it is a reality um
so if you don't already know how to do
it
take a course learn if you don't have
that already
easily available please consider taking
this secure software development
fundamentals it's a free course
there's a url right there i'll show it
again later it's on edx
it costs you exactly zero dollars costs
you nothing
and it will help you understand how to
develop i'll go over some basics
of that but really take a course won't
take long
and of course it's more than learning
apply what you learn right
so make the secure that you develop
secure by default make it easy to use
securely
harden it against the tax uh make it so
that
well when the user receives it it's
ready to go
secure and to run securely number two if
you're developing open source software
work to earn the best cii best practices
badge there's another url
i'll talk more about these in a moment
um
but basically it's a list of criteria
that if you do are
going to more to increase the likelihood
of producing secure software number
three
use a lot of tools to find
vulnerabilities in your continuous
integration pipeline
there's a lot of different kinds of
tools available i've listed some common
ones here you know quality scanners
aka linters there's security code
scanners
there's secret standing there's uh
software component analysis there's web
application scanners there are fuzzers
um you want to use multiple cool
multiple different kinds of tools you
want to use multiple tools
tools just by themselves aren't enough
to make software secure
you still have to know how to make
secure software in particular
but they can be an important part of
that
of making secure software next monitor
for known vulnerabilities and what you
depend on nowadays
most software brings in a lot of other
software if
those dependencies have vulnerabilities
then
that may become a vulnerability in the
system that you've created using them
so you need to monitor them and update
when they're vulnerable
which means number five you need to
enable
rapid update of your dependencies you
know
once you find out that there's a known
vulnerability
you need to be able to quickly update
quickly ship
how do you do that well package managers
and automated tests are keys to that
because package managers automate the
process of managing your dependencies
and there's different
kinds but you need to use them and your
tests
your automated tests should include
negative tests a test to make sure that
things that shouldn't work
stay not working and be thorough enough
to
you know to ship if it passes some
people ask me well how much do i need to
test and the answer is
um you make enough of an automated test
suite so that
if it passes your test suite it's ready
to ship if it's not
there yet then your automated test suite
is not good enough yet
number six evaluate before selecting
dependencies
um i guess in some sense that's out of
order but you basically
before you bring into dependency make
sure
you evaluate it make sure you're
bringing in the one you think you're
bringing in
make it easy for your users to update
things like providing stable apis so
that they can quickly update when
there's a problem
and finally number eight continuously
update
attacks get better so attack so
defenders also need to get better
now i don't want you to get the idea
that
perfection is the one and only goal here
vulnerabilities are risks it's hard to
eliminate all risks
but you can manage risks you can
mitigate them you reduce the likelihood
you can reduce their impacts
um but you have to actually think about
doing that
david there is one question in the
question q a if you want to
um yeah we i'm happy to take questions
as we go we probably need to
uh we it might be wise to have not too
many because we're
we after i'm done with my presentation
i'm hoping to have an
open uh you know an open uh set of
questions but yeah let's uh
please do i want to answer questions
uh oh i need to click on things let's
see where do i click
q a all right uh if i'm trying to select
them
to add an application how would the
badges help me um let's see here uh
basically the badges
will give you an idea of whether or not
those projects are working to develop
secure software
and you know where they stand so
um trying to achieve the best practices
for your own project helps your project
get secure
looking for projects that have achieved
those badges or at least are well on the
way to achieving them
gives you confidence that the projects
you're bringing in that your
as your dependencies are in fact more
likely to be secure
all right so let me talk a little bit
about some of the things that i um i
gave in my summary slide i talked about
this course about
developing about secure software
development fundamentals
it's a set of three free courses
it's not a huge time commitment you've
got approximate hours here
i mean if you took an hour a day you'd
be done in less than two weeks
um and it covers these topics um
you know how to design what are the
design principles for security
things like lease privileges and lease
privilege how to apply those
uh how to examine designs how do you use
accept lists and not delight lists to
constrain untrusted inputs if you're
taking inputs from somebody you can't
trust
you should be very very strict on what
you accept
define very strict patterns on these are
the only
input values allowed and just reject
everything else this
is incredibly effective effective on
limiting a lot of attacks
know the most common kinds of
vulnerabilities you know there's various
top 10 and top 25 lists
and then how to prevent each one i'll
use hardening
methods so that yes you're probably
going to have some bugs in your code but
not all bugs are equal
you can take a lot of steps to reduce
the likelihood
that a bug is a vulnerability i
already mentioned adding a lot of
vulnerability detection tools to your ci
pipeline it talks in more detail what
the different kinds of common tools are
their pluses their
their strengths or weaknesses how to
apply them
um and of course and this course unlike
many has materials
uh specific to using and developing open
source software
uh we've got some something you need to
put mute on
all right um one nice thing about this
little this course is not only is it
free
but it has a large number of small
modules and almost all of them have a
little quiz at the end this is a very
simple technique but i found that
it's really really helpful to stay on
track instead of just you know blindly
reading oh wait i got a little quiz i
gotta answer my quiz and that really
helps
you can pay to try to earn a certificate
you don't have to
but some people want to be able to prove
that they learn the material
and so we offer that as well by the way
this is a project within the open source
security
foundation's best practices working
group
all right let me talk a little bit about
some of those key points that are
covered in much more detail in that
course or other courses
about developing secure software so i've
heard some people say that hey my
software doesn't have a design well your
software might not have a
documented design but if it runs it has
a design because the design is simply
how you divide your problem into
components and how they interact
that's how i'll ultimate by design
working software always has a design
but some designs are way better than
others in terms of being secure
so there are some things called design
principles which are basically rules of
thumb
to help you avoid common serious design
flaws
and there's a number of time-tested
design principles things like
least privilege give your software the
least privilege it can
to work because that greatly reduces
the impacts if there's a security
problem of some kind
another one is complete mediation also
known as non-bypassability in other
words
if there's some check that's important
for security
make sure an attacker can't bypass it
it's remarkable
how many client-side javascript programs
and mobile applications
fail this because they insert security
checks
in code that's going to be running on a
computer you can't trust
this happens over and over again and by
the way the problem with things like
least
failing to know about or apply least
privilege or non-bypassability
is that it's often a lot of work to
change your code later to fix the
problem
whereas if you knew about them ahead of
time and applied them it's no big deal
i've often heard that security can be
expensive
well it's it's not usually very
expensive
if you think about it ahead of time but
if you have to
rejigger all your code um trying to
retrofit security is typically what's
expensive
not security but retrofitting security
oh yeah that can be very expensive
i mentioned earlier you need to know the
most common kinds of vulnerabilities and
how to avoid them
depending on you measure over 90 or
maybe even 99
of vulnerabilities fit into a relatively
small set
of categories so if you know about those
categories and know how to prevent each
one and
and do that you can re reduce your
vulnerabilities by
at least an order of magnitude there are
some widely
used carefully crafted lists of common
vulnerabilities
you should know them you should use them
if you're using web applications a lot
of folks use the os top 10 for web
applications
uh if you're doing anything else a
commonly used list is the cwe top 25
list
um top 25 25 is actually a little bit of
misleading because they do list 25 but
they also list some extras
on the cusp which are a couple extra
that aren't the top 25 but maybe you
should think about those too
the good thing is once you know about
these common kinds of vulnerabilities
and how to avoid them
you squash an incredible number of
vulnerabilities in your software
so here's some examples things like
injection vulnerability something
there's a common problem that's can be a
disaster in particular for web
applications
called sql injection um and
these are incredibly easy to counter if
instead of
concatenating strings you use something
called prepared statements
then the code is easier to see
it's sometimes faster it's easier
understand
and it'll counter sql injection attacks
another common problem is cross-site
scripting another problem is buffer
overflows which is
actually a subset of a larger category
called memory safety failures
these are still endemic 70 of the chrome
vulnerabilities
and of microsoft's vulnerabilities um
are
memory safety failures and have been for
many many years
um so once you know about these you can
start
countering them and eliminating them as
a problem for your software
as vulnerabilities now i mentioned
earlier you need to do more than
just knowing your head you need to apply
but you know it's hard to be perfect
so it's important to also add
vulnerability detection tools
to your ci pipeline the key here is to
detect
problems early okay
now there's many many different kinds of
tools you should include multiple kinds
and
in many cases include multiple zones of
the same kind
you can think of tools as a kind of
automated
reviewer different reviewers human
reviews will notice different problems
different tools notice different
problems and so you really want to bring
a sweet to them
to to to bear practically all tools
have both false positives and false
negatives they're almost always going to
have at least one and typically
both um false positive means that it's
gonna report something that
isn't really a vulnerability false
negative means it's not gonna report
something and it was a it was a
vulnerability
uh what does this mean you still need to
think
um the false positives means just
because a tool reports something it
doesn't mean that's an
actual problem you need to figure out
what to do about it maybe you don't need
to change your code maybe you just need
to tell the tool that
no that's not really a vulnerability or
maybe you need to change how you do this
develop your software so that that false
positive is no longer triggered
um false negatives are a problem of
course because
the tools aren't going to find
everything which means you still need to
know how to develop secure software you
still need to
apply those design principles again
try to have many tools now there is a
really
different kind of strategy you'll need
to apply depending on whether or not
you're doing a greenfield project or a
brownfield project by greenfield i mean
it's a new start there's no code
brownfield oh man
here it is congratulations it's a
million lines of code it may have been
around for years
okay if it's greenfield a new start
typically you want to add the tools
right now
probably as many as you can as amazing
as you can get them into your
ci pipeline make them really sensitive
why
because the instant you start writing
code at all it'll immediately warn you
about
problems and constructs that are
dangerous and you can
oh i guess i see i see that do this
instead
and then all the rest of the code will
apply that those lessons
brownfield is very very different okay
if it's an existing
project you typically need to add tools
very slowly
and start by um greatly reducing their
sensitivity
really limit what they report and then
slowly increase their sensitivity over
time
the problem here is that if you just add
a whole bunch of tools
and make them sensitive you'll be
completely overwhelmed with reports
oh look there's a billion reports um
i can't possibly handle that right okay
start with most with a very few tools
start with most important
limit and then add things over time
there's a question earlier about the cia
best practices badge let me talk a
little bit more about that
the ci best practices badge is
essentially
a list of criteria of a bunch of best
practices for open source projects
and they're the goal of those criteria
is to better improve quality and
security
so here's an example of some of these
criteria you know the project sites must
support https
they must use at least one automated
test suite at least one static code
analysis tool must be applied
that's a tool to analyze the code
without running it
and the project must publish the process
for reporting vulnerabilities because
you know
even after you do everything there may
still be a vulnerability
make it as easy as possible people
report it back to you
and these are based on the practices of
well-run open source software projects
if an open source software project meets
those criteria it earns a badge
and this enables projects and potential
users to know its status
so there's that question earlier about
you know oh if i may
if i'm a potential user what do these do
for me well they help you figure out oh
wait a minute this project is working
hard to apply a lot of good practices
uh there are three actually three batch
levels passing silver and gold
but i'll note that even getting a
passing badge is
a significant achievement um
participation is widespread
um i have on the slide deck is 3 700
it's actually over 3 900 we're getting
really close to 4
000 participating projects there's over
500
passing projects and you can see the
current statistics right there in that
url
and this is also a project within the
open ssf best practices working group
now if you are a user of open source
software
okay another including by the way a
developer software that's you
using other open software as a
dependency and by the way that includes
most software developers
so what do you do well number one is
there evidence that's developers work to
make it secure
and oh by the way all those things i
just told you before
about how should developers develop
secure software
now your job is to look to see if
they're doing that okay you know are
they doing things like applying the ci
best practices match
um number two is it easy to use securely
three is it maintained
you wanna look for things like recent
commits multiple developers
does it have significant use now i have
to be careful here there is a
real problem in the software development
world with uh what i call
fad engineering you know oh big company
x uses it therefore that must be the
right software for me no actually they
probably have very very different
problems than
you do um so you know just because
somebody else uses it does not mean
it's an appropriate software it's
appropriate software for your
circumstance
however there is something to it if
there are no users
there's probably going to be no
reviewers it's probably not going to be
maintained well in the future
so you know it should have some use um
what's the software license
uh we still have people today who have
the misguided thought
that if there's no license on the
software um it's
open source or it's usable by anybody uh
the law around the world has not changed
because some people think that okay the
law is the law
and if you if you want to be allowed to
use the software it has to be licensed
this isn't some ideal this is what law
what laws around the world say um so
what do you
and there are various tools that can
help you identify the components within
them to figure out things like the
license
and also uh if there's known
vulnerabilities in them
if it's important what is your own
evaluation okay and the great thing
about open source software is that makes
it possible
um i like to note to folks that
citizenship isn't trustworthiness
if you want to trust something look at
the code
and did you acquire it securely and the
bigger problem there biggest problem
there is
do you require the right thing now i
mentioned evaluation
if the software is important to you not
examining it is a risk if you just take
some bits
whether it's open source or proprietary
that's a risk
okay um so it's i think it's often a
good idea
to review the software because even a
brief review of the code can give some
insight
you know again is there evidence that
developers are trying to develop secure
software
um you can often find some evidence of
insecure woefully incomplete software um
you know run some tools against it you
can look for evidence of maliciousness
and of course you know trying to figure
out the likelihood that packages were
developed
were generated from the source code it
claims and there are folks who can do
that for you for a fee if you want to do
it
now when you're downloading some
software there are some things to think
about and
there are some complicated things before
you go complicated there's some simple
things you can do
that can lower risks with almost no cost
first of all
double check the name make sure you have
exactly the
correct name before you add a package as
your dependency or download it for use
today the most common kind of malicious
attack
in on open source software is typo
squatting creating
projects that have similar names but not
exactly the correct names
why because attackers can take the easy
road and this is easy instead of trying
to subvert the soft just
make another project uh check for dashes
versus
underscores ones versus l's unicode
characters
and also check its popularity things
like you know
uh when was it released was the download
counts and so on
um if if you were trying about to use a
package you know has been around for 10
years and it's widely used
and oh look here's this package it was
created last month it's got three
downloads
that's not it right you don't need to be
a genius
to realize that's not the what you were
looking for
so you know some simple checks can
actually
avoid a lot of problems and of course
download install
and trustworthy way you know whatever
its usual redistribution
approach try to use hdbs instead of http
um uh one technique that is
is actually really helpful is download
and delay download
but don't install it quite yet
particularly if you're doing
application level packages uh because
sometimes if a system
if a site if a download site gets
attacked it's noticed it gets fixed
but if you waited a little bit then um
you didn't end up in installing the
maliciously the maliciously subverted
one
i'll try to verify it's digitally signed
but the challenge there
is that there are challenges today with
digital signature and verification i'll
talk more about some efforts to try to
deal with that
later now of course when you're
operating the software
you know protect detect respond you need
to protect
protection is great but you know things
happen so you also need to detect and
respond
to attacks constantly monitor and if a
vulnerability is found in a dependency
examine it quickly
if you know it can't be exploited your
environment fine but otherwise you want
to rapidly update
test ship as i mentioned earlier and the
key here is you've got to be
faster than your attackers if you're
waiting a month
that's probably pointless because the
attackers aren't waiting a month
as soon as the vulnerabilities become
known the clock is
ticking
i don't have a lot of time to talk about
it but i should just note that
although attackers certainly attack
vulnerabilities in the software itself
attackers also attack the process where
where software uh emerges from
developers
heads all the way out to eventually
being used
i mean so there is a process that uh
that is used to develop software
typically developers create a local
environment
it gets merged into some data source and
data repository
build verify approve released as some
sort of distribution platform
and then either selected directly by
users are selected and brought into
larger systems
which build and build and build and of
course attackers can attack
all those steps but the okay
but the good news is that there are many
ways to counter
those once you realize oh wait attackers
will try to attack me
but i don't just have to accept that i
can actively work to counter them
things like using two-factor
authentication
for my repository so that um arbitrary
people can't just guess a password
and break in and take over control over
my software
there is no silver bullet
okay um now
uh so you really need to think about a
number of different things now what's
coming in the future
um my crystal ball's a little fuzzy
um but uh my ba here are my best guesses
um i think we're going to see more help
when evaluating open source
offer i'll note that open ssf is working
on providing a data dashboard
metrics open ssf.org chaos is working to
define more metrics
there's a lot of folks working on trying
to make it easier
to evaluate open source software so that
at least
you know hey there's three different
open source software packages which one
should i use
you can have better information next up
um wider use adoption and requiring
software bill materials
a little earlier this year the u.s white
house released something called the
executive order on cyber security it
includes a number of things including a
number
of requirements and statements about
software build materials
um today generally when users get some
software
they have no idea what's inside them
okay and it looks a whole lot like
the world of medicine looked like in the
early 1900s late 1800s
um where you know people would hand you
medicine and lord or nose was in there
uh you know might be uh some some
illicit drugs or things that you might
not have otherwise wanted to put in your
body
um and yet for software we have no idea
what's inside there
um there are package managers can
already track within
within single ecosystems of the software
within a system
but there are standards now in in
development
uh or released that uh let you share
software build materials you know those
the ingredients of a larger piece of
software
um i'll note that spdx exists today it's
uh it's now um at the prf level in iso
um uh and there's some other work as
well
so so basically there's already work on
going to enable
sharing the software build materials and
i expect to see more of that in the days
ahead
i think package managers and
repositories are going to improve their
counter measures
there's something called verified
reproducible builds which lets you
verify
that the bits that you're about to
install really did come
from the source code that was evaluated
by developers
um the lack of this was for example a
problem for the recent solarwinds
debacle with orion
where the code that was being installed
and run
was actually not generated strictly from
the
source code that was developed by the
developers you know the developers
developed code and they reviewed it
but that's not what was used to be
shipped to
use developers because someone subverted
of the developer development process the
build process actually
um cryptographic signature verification
from a mathematical point of view
cryptographic signatures are solved we
know how to do it
math-wise but there's a lot more to the
world than mathematics
uh applying cryptographic signature
verification in the real world has
turned out to be a
challenging problem and so uh one
one linux foundation project is called
sig store which is working hard
to make uh cryptographic signature
verification much easier
also working on improving uh get signing
abilities
um integrity and station there are
things like
in toto and alvarium to help with uh
attestation of
integrity increased use of memory safe
and safe
languages um if performance is not
super important there's a huge number of
programming languages
that are available that are also memory
safe but when you really need
uh strong very good performance
a lot of programs today are written in
cnc plus plus which are not memory safe
and this has led to 70 of the
vulnerabilities today in a lot of
systems
are memory safety problems so increased
use of languages that just prevent this
whole cloth
uh i think is uh is very promising uh
and is likely to continue in the future
i think the form methods are going to
continue to be used in rare specialized
tasks i'd like to see a little more of
that but i i don't think that's going to
be common
uh having to be proved wrong in that but
i think we are going to see them in some
specialized tasks
now please work with others to make
things
better okay because the future is
whatever we collectively work to make it
if you are interested in improving open
source offer
the open source office security then the
answer then is get involved okay and
here are just
some of the organizations i've mentioned
most of them now
uh there's of course the open source
security foundation
uh sig store in toto um
there's many others um and there's many
others frankly i'm not
on this on this list here though the
point here is if you want to improve the
security of open source software get
involved
this is not to say that oh my gosh open
source software security is a disaster
not at all
um you know there's a lot of really
secure open source software
um open source software has some real
potential advantages
for security because many people can
review it
and and and get it fixed but those
potentials are not always lived up to
and frankly we don't want just good we
want
really good because we're all dependent
on this stuff
so we want to make things
better and better over time
which really leads to this bigger point
here
developing deploying secure software
it's really a journey
it's a journey of learning it's enjoying
improving it's not
really a singular event because of
the way the english language works it's
often easier to use
you know perfections and goals but the
reality is
that um there's always going to be ways
to improve security even if it's not
vulnerable hey you know we can change
the software
so that it's even less likely to get a
vulnerability later it's going to have
stronger defenses
here right now right below are just a
few links to
a few of the things that i mentioned
here i already mentioned the free course
i don't have time to cover a whole
course in this very short time
but i'm hoping i've given you a flavor
of it because in the end i think that
that's
in many ways the most important thing is
understanding
some education some training once you
know how to develop secure software
a lot of other things can become easier
and it's one of those things that will
pay you dividends through the rest of
your software development career
um the best practices for structure.org
is where the ci best practices badge
project um
well lives or at least you know that's
where you can get started get a badge
um here's a little guide on how to use
tools there's many other guides
but you know the key is get some tools
into your process so that it can start
into your ci process
so that you can start detecting
vulnerabilities um
building on what you already learned
from you know some course of some kind
all right so um i wanted to leave a lot
of time for questions
so i'm uh i i tried to get through i
know a lot of material
relatively quickly i have lots of backup
slides if you
want to ask specific questions or go in
a particular way but i'm really
interested in helping
you today i want people to leave here
feeling that the important questions to
them were answered
um and i just want to point out that
this is of course part of the lf live
mentorship
series uh and that's really kind of the
goal of all
of these um events uh for
in lf live mentorship is basically we're
trying to give you some information
but we also want to you know discuss
and answer your questions to the best we
can um
so that you can go away and apply and
you know and uh you know be glad that
you were part of the experience
all right with that um let's see here
uh i'm gonna i guess i'm going to start
with looking at some of the questions up
that seems to have been built up as we
went um so let's see here
oh yes okay so the c the top 25 there's
a link there sure
um you know there's uh if you if you're
just doing cdb top 25 you should be able
to find it quite quickly
um yeah so and in fact
if you take that uh the course that i've
been mentioning earlier which by the way
i make no money
if you go to if you go to edx and you
take the course i make no money
you pay no money i am very very excited
about this
particular topic i think it's very very
important
and one of the things that i made sure
because i actually
wrote that course is that i made sure it
covered
all those top things so you will
actually walk through those various top
items
and see various options on how to
counter eagle
what is it and how do you counter them
all right how are we going to address
the gap to map security from
cve cpe to s-bomb squid
uh connection
okay uh so um so regarding cve
cpes and so on um i think that the
okay so for those of you who aren't
familiar with this um
there is a well-known method for
identifying
vulnerabilities uh software
vulnerabilities it doesn't
i don't it doesn't um identify them all
but it covers many it's probably the
most
most complete collection of any publicly
accessible list
of vulnerabilities um and the idea is
pretty straightforward every
vulnerability has a unique id
and they look like cve dash year it was
reported dash
some other number to make it unique um
the current problem today with cves is
although they report vulnerabilities
they don't record almost
all the vulnerabilities they don't
record
in their information any way to
automatically link the vulnerability
report to the software
that is vulnerable um there's typically
some textual description
um and you know what in a world where
maybe you had a hundred programs that's
fine
you can live with that you don't need to
worry about automation
um i did a you know there's literally
millions of open source software
projects
today that is complete insanity
to think you're going to be able to do
that by hand today there are a number of
projects which
uh which are different but share the
same name there are a number of projects
which have
multiple different names for the same
thing trying to handle that
with a human is ridiculous now the cve
does attempt to do this with something
called cpes
but they but almost no projects have
cpes today they're not really supporting
them
they keep saying they're going to use
swifts which don't actually work for
this case i don't know why they keep
saying that switzer going to work when
it's known they're not going to work
because most the software and there's
open source and swifts require
unique hashes uh for the x
for the uh for the binaries oh by the
way
you can recompile that's a thing so
it just doesn't make any sense um so
what are we doing to address
i think a number of people have
repeatedly told the
cve folks that this is a critical thing
to do
um i think the reality is either the cve
process is
fixed to to address that or
that the community will abandon the cve
process and switch to something that
actually resolves the problem
i'm kind of hoping that the cv it took a
lot of effort for the cve folks to do
what they did
i'm hoping that the cve folks will fix
their process
so that there can be an automatic
connection but in my mind there's really
no point in reporting vulnerabilities
without a way to connect it to the
software that's vulnerable it doesn't
make any sense to me
and it doesn't make any sense to a lot
of other people too um
i realize they do it with human readable
text
that doesn't make it also doesn't make
sense in a world with millions and
millions
of software projects so i'm hoping that
they'll fix it
if not i expect the community will come
up with an alternative
um that actually resolves the problem
all right
what do you suggest the learning
strategy for the beginner well hey
i have an x i've pointed that out x
course start there
um it's not complicated you click and
learn it's it's
a simple little reading materials uh and
uh and click on quizzes as you go along
it's not it's not fancy
um that's a good place to start there's
always something to learn i've been
doing this for a long time and there's
always new things to learn um so
you know start with you know simple
courses like that like that x course
and then just be open to learning okay
just keep
you know keep monitoring things oh look
a new kind of vulnerability has been
discovered
let me i'll read the article about that
okay um
all right now let's see here i think
there's a key let me go that was from
the chat
let me go look at the uh
q and a i got to find where there we go
q a all right
uh so i'm going to try to answer open up
from the q a sections
uh what vetting occurs to prevent bad
actors from getting involved in open
source security and subverting these
proposed
improvements in some way um
the honest the answer is actually the
same is true for proprietary software
okay which
is you make sure what you should be
doing
is having other people review that code
either before it's employed
or afterwards to look at the code to
find those problems
typical and most the biggest risk is
really open source software projects
with single developers in that case
there often isn't a second person who
can review it other than maybe a
reviewer
later potential users who check well the
advantage of open source is that you
can't
anybody not just the developers can look
um as the projects get larger typically
they start requiring more and more
review by other people and so that makes
it much more risky
for an attacker to slip in and propose
subverted improvements i'll note there
actually
have been some efforts to insert
malicious code that don't that
haven't worked um somebody tried to
subvert the uh insert a malicious code
someone let's just go into the linux
kernel um almost 20 years ago i think
it's like 2003
and being up year may not be quite right
but basically they tried to insert code
that looked right
but it used a single equal instead of a
double equal
a very uh subtle hard to see flaw if you
weren't used to this sort of thing
um that would quietly subvert you know
enable someone to take over a
linux-based system it was
that code was never included in a real
linux
kernel uh version it was immediately
detected by the kernel developers
uh more recently some develop some
researchers from university of minnesota
tried to create some vulnerable code
and tried to insert it get it added to
the linux kernel
um the way they did it frankly was not
appropriate
i'm not a fan of how they did it but you
know what since they did it i will
we may as well learn from it what they
did and i'll note that once again
their attempts to insert vulnerabilities
were immediately rejected
uh by the linux kernel developers
um and so therefore um you know
both those are linux kernel examples let
me add a third one
um this is a very very different one
also uh years ago
borland sold a proprietary database
program
uh for years and it and and they had
some success in the medical community
but eventually
it just wasn't profitable and so they
decided
after many many years of releasing as a
proprietary program
they decided to sell as a proprietary
program they released it as an
open source software program um within
less than a year
um months i don't remember exactly how
long
um someone found
um uh a a subversion that looked for
all the world like a maliciously
subverted um uh back door
basically if you entered your the
username of politically and the password
correct
uh you were suddenly the database
administrator this was not documented in
fact was of course a very very bad idea
now maybe this wasn't an intentional
malicious backdoor it certainly looks
like one though
and whether or not it was it shows that
hey it was soul's proprietary software
for many many many years
nobody noticed this
is released as open source offer people
noticed
okay uh so while that's no guarantee
that does at least provide decent
evidence that people really do
look at code open source software code
and they really do
detect and counter problems all right
next question what language is the most
vulnerable to attacks
in developing open source software
oh that one's actually harder to answer
than you might
think um let me let me
reverse the question a little bit
because i think
um whoops because i think
that um i mean not this
particular question or may not have had
this line of thinking but i have seen
this live thinking where
hey if i just chose language x
i will have no more vulnerabilities and
let me just cut that off right away
there is no programming language
that ensures that there are no
vulnerabilities possible of any kind
okay it is always possible to make
mistakes
in any programming language and that
result and what you didn't
expect okay now that said
some languages do allow for a kind of
uh foot gunning that is harder to do in
any other language
um i think probably the poster trial for
this kind of thing and
i'm sure no one is shocked by this is
the pair of programming languages c
and c plus plus um they're not
necessarily awful languages and
they were designed for a particular
circumstance and for a particular
situation
the problem with cnc plus plus is that
they assume that the programmer never
ever makes a mistake and the programmer
is willing to take great pains and care
to check everything so hey before you
access an array you're going to make
sure
that the array access is within bounds
if you
if you acc if you read from a pointer or
right to a border that port is going to
be where you wanted it to be
okay um
it also assumes that the pro that the
software developer
is very very aware and has studied
carefully the specification because cnc
plus plus have a huge number of
undefined constructs
that a lot of people frankly are
surprised by you know they they
a lot of software developers think even
if they write and see
hey if i add one to the largest integer
that becomes the most negative integer
right no that is undefined behavior
it'll probably result in a vulnerability
it will not necessarily result in
wrapping around
oh but wait a minute i thought computers
did that that's
a machine thing you're using c c has
different rules
and um so i i think you know i mentioned
earlier
chrome 70 of its vulnerabilities
the last number of years microsoft
across it software 70
of their vulnerabilities are all due to
memory safety issues
um and c and c plus plus are memory
unsafe
always all use of memory uh
all use of cnc plus plus um
always allows memory safety problems
there's no protections against memory
safety issues
built into the language now it's true
that some c-plus plus classes
if you use them in certain ways will
protect against some memory safety
problems
but in general but if it's easy to
escape out of and in fact it's easy to
escape out of them without realizing
that you're escaping out of them
so um those are are probably the most
dangerous in terms of vulnerabilities
but
um many other languages you can have
vulnerabilities in any language
um i mentioned earlier a push
increasingly towards memory safe
languages
languages like rust and so on now it's
not that you can't have memory safety
problems in languages like rust
or ada or many other or c sharp
um but the difference is that you have
to specifically enable
the unsafe behavior so they're safe
normally
and then you can disable the safeties in
special cases when you need them
but as long as you limit the unsafe code
to very small sets you can check
carefully
much much less likely to have at least
many classes of vulnerabilities
okay so that said can you have
vulnerabilities in java
yes absolutely can you have many in the
other language absolutely
okay um so but but there's
but there's a trade-off and all too
often it's just too hard today
for software developers to be perfect in
every way
and that makes it harder to write secure
software in cnc plus plus
not impossible harder all right
um next uh let's see here what static
code analysis tools do you recommend
what about dynamic code analysis tools
oh my goodness
oh okay so first of all i need to
clarify
that um you know different tools
are better for different circumstances
okay um and so it's really not a matter
of here's the one tool
and off you go okay um
uh let me so that said let me let me uh
hit the dynamic analysis tools first um
if you're doing a web application
scanner there's a huge number of them
and i'm not
uh and it's hard to keep track but i've
used osap many times i've been very
happy with it so there's one
are there others you bet and there's a
lot of good ones um if
using fuzzers uh there's tools like afl
plus plus which is basically the uh a
fork and a maintained fork of american
fuzzy lop
that's something called a coverage
guided fuzzer uh coverage guided fuzzers
are amazing they have made it much
easier to apply fuzzing
uh without having to be um uh you know
really really uh basically they've
lowered the barriers to entry
as far as static code analysis tools
that's way harder
almost every language has at least one
linter
use at least one of those as far as
static analysis tools that's really
challenging and a lot of it depends on
the languages that you're using
i know a lot of folks use coverity which
is a proprietary tool or fortify
there's also just a boatload of other
tools
now one complication that i should also
note
uh that makes it a little challenging
for me to recommend tools is that some
of the proprietary tools
come with something called uh dewitt
clauses and their licenses
i'm very much opposed to these things
dewitt clauses are i think should be
straight up illegal
but basically they say that if you're
going to use the software
you can't publish results publicly
unless we approve and of course
the tool maker is not going to prove
anything that doesn't say the tool is
wonderful
and so it's had an incredible chilling
effect
i believe that this that these should be
just
straight up illegal there's a lot of
other free speech laws in the u.s
that prohibit these kinds of things
somehow this has
flown under the radar um and once one
supplier adds to it uh
clause um other vendors are typically
pressured uh to add clauses to their
tools too
because otherwise you know they can
people can talk bad about their tool but
not their competitors so
it's a it's a bad situation and it makes
it harder
to honestly give you recommendations
because what i really need to do is go
grab
benchmarks that people have done that
are published
and it's right now very very hard to get
that kind of data
so i've given you just some personal
answers
but in the longer term i'd like to see
more and more tools
and more evaluations public so that we
can make
uh you know a better evaluation
community wide all right
uh how can you speak to how to best man
and manage open source software
dependency chain today
if i evaluate widget x how do i
manufacture uses gadget gadget a
which uses gizmo b and so on down to the
bottom turtle
i know exactly what you're talking about
yes indeed it's turtles all the way down
all right um
it is something of a challenge um
how can i best manage a dependency
challenge today
um really if you are developing software
or receiving software the the number one
thing you can do
is you know is look at the ingredients
what's going in
because you can compare those there are
a number of tools that work to compare
um known vulnerabilities with the
software and the version the software
that's actually in there
um and you know what if it's known if if
it's vulnerable come
complain and say hey wait a minute
you're you're depending on an old
version
you need to update and i think right now
today that's uh one of the key things
is going and complaining to your
upstream and you know what
if we weren't talking about software if
we were talking about
physical devices with no software at all
that's actually how we would do it also
okay if i'm building a device made of
other devices which in turn are made of
other devices um
you would look at your at least at the
major components and probably look a
little further
to see if everything's okay and if you
saw a problem you would go and complain
you know to your what's called the
upstream to think of things in terms of
a river flowing down to
you you go to your upstream say wait a
minute the thing you're using in there
has a problem go get that fix get it
updated or replace it do something
and really i think that's what's going
to going to
need what we're going to need is more
and more people
running tools detecting problems
reporting back saying go fix go fix go
fix
and getting people to start moving and
updating because today
the problem is often that a
vulnerability is found
but somebody uses it it uses an old
version doesn't update
and then people use it end up with this
old
obsolete sub component so it's not
it's not insolvable we just need to get
people moving
all right really great present oh well
thank you very much uh what's the best
way to do responsible disclosure for
open source software with a known
vulnerability
um all right uh let me see just a uh a
quick
side note because you asked me a
question um
i'm actually not a fan of the phrase
responsible disclosure i prefer the
phrase
coordinated disclosure um the folks who
originally coined the term
responsible disclosure actually
recommend using the term
coordinated disclosure instead because
it implies that doing anything other
than that process is irresponsible
and i don't think that's quite true um
let's see here so in any case um
typically for coordinator disclosure
you report to the supplier um and i'm
a fan of coordinating disclosure with a
time limit in other words not just
reporting
but saying hey wait if you don't report
to the world within some reasonable time
and fix it if you don't fix it with a
reasonable time i'm going to tell the
world
now unfortunately there's still a lot of
i'm not sure i should call them bad
actors but
um uh
poor about poorly behaved suppliers
who instead will try to threaten me with
lawsuits
uh if you expose their problems to
the fact that they have a vulnerability
to the world
um but you know what um too bad
um you wrote the software you included a
vulnerability in it
um it's your job to fix it um
uh and you know if if you won't fix it
then i think the public has a right to
know
that the uh software that they were
thinking about using is vulnerable maybe
they shouldn't be using it
um if you don't like that answer then
please go fix it
ideally start writing your software
secure in the first place
to be secure in the first place um so
what's the best way to do
uh disclosure to open source software
well
the number one thing to do is actually
not your problem
but the open source software projects
problem and that is the open source
offer project should tell everybody
how to report vulnerabilities to it that
is
one of the cii best practices criteria
i'll also note that is one of the most
commonly missed
criteria in other words when a project
doesn't
get a passing badge immediately this is
one of the most common reasons for it is
they haven't told anybody
how to report vulnerabilities to the
project
um and you know there are reasons for it
i understand but you still need to do it
um so the best way is to go to the
project page
notice that they have told you how to do
it and then
go report it okay all right that's a
little bit of a cheat
what happens if i go to the project and
in fact
they haven't told me how to report a
vulnerability
which is unfortunately a common case
actually it's common case for a lot of
open source and closed source software
so what do you do then well what you do
is you go
find a way to contact them for example
if they're on github you can at least
probably open an issue
and say hey i think i may have found a
vulnerability in your software
please contact me give some contact info
uh
let's talk about this in most cases i
recommend what's called a coordinated
disclosure in other words
don't reveal publicly immediately
exactly what the vulnerability is
and the reason is that attackers
will look for that information and will
start exploiting
customers immediate people customers
people who are using that software
right away and you know that's not fair
because the users of that software had
no reason to know there was a
vulnerability
um and it's going to typically take some
time for the supplier of the software
to create a proper update and fix and so
on so
it's often best to try to do this
quietly
now when is that not true well sometimes
that's not so true for example
if all the attackers already know about
the vulnerability it may be the only
organization that doesn't know about the
vulnerability
is the project um
secrecy isn't so important maybe what's
important now is getting it fixed well
and quickly um but really i think right
now is
find a way ideally use whatever process
they have for reporting
if they don't have one quietly ask them
create one and coordinate so that you
can report the vulnerability to them
give them a time limit you can negotiate
a time limit there's various discussions
on what a time limit should be a lot of
suppliers think the time limits should
be really long
a lot of people who are potentially
vulnerable who
are possibly impacted by these
vulnerabilities want them very short
but um you know a lot of these things
can be fixed in
a week or two weeks uh 45 days on the
outset
and the outside um you know some will
even give up to 90 days but you
basically
you try to trade a timeline because
otherwise it's easy
just to let these things go on and on
and
the problem with that is of course with
that no deadline and just going on and
on eventually attackers are going to
start exploiting it
there attackers may find it
independently heck they may have already
found it independently and
are already explaining it so once a
vulnerability is found
it needs to get priority well if it's
important vulnerability it needs to get
priority attention get
fixed uh now if it's a if it's a
low level of importance in other words
things like
this almost normally never matters but
in this really quirky weird edge case
uh edge use that most people wouldn't be
doing it could be exploited
you know maybe in terms of you know it
could be shut down
you know not you know not revealing any
data just you know maybe it's a denial
of service and an incredibly weird edge
case maybe that's not so important
and maybe you can give more time for
that um
but for super important vulnerabilities
you want to get
them worked off quickly okay so i'm
hoping that answers that question
i'll note that the open ssf actually has
another group the vulnerability
disclosures working group where they're
discussing things like that and there's
also other groups like first and so on
that have some information about how to
report vulnerabilities and
vulnerability process processes in
general
um okay let me go the next question i
have a project with a lot of dependable
updates have stacked up
some of the updates are breaking to the
existing code
oh how do you recommend updating the
code
oh my goodness well i suppose i could
just say carefully and leave it at that
but that's not really fair
all right um well first of all
you have my sympathy cause i've lived
that
that joy many many a time um
so actually so let me quickly go on a
hobby horse i i mentioned this in my
presentation earlier
if you are developing software for use
by
others you should be ashamed
if your api changes in ways where you're
making it hard for your users to update
oh my goodness i misspelled the old
interface
great add the new correctly spelled keep
the old one around
why does it matter to you that it's not
but
my api has five
interfaces instead of four how about
that why don't you think about the users
for a change
okay for the user's point of view
anything that
is a breaking change is a big deal
because
oh they just have to rename something or
oh they just have to restructure
some code most people have other things
to do with their lives
than dealing with your api nonsense okay
so please please please
try to make it so that software you
develop for others
isn't just break isn't breaking or at
least not breaking often
okay try to avoid it give people lots of
time to update
sure there are cases where you really
just have to do a breaking change
okay give them warning make it as easy
as possible to update
um i know the python 3 folks thought oh
hey
the python 2 to 3 is easy took them
years and years and years and years and
then
and they finally after a lot of ignoring
the users
finally ended up changing python 3 to
make it easier
to update from two um you don't need to
do that you don't need to abuse your
users
okay be good to them not malicious to
them
all right so uh but you're not in this
you're unfortunately the other
circumstance some of the updates
broker code this is a problem um
how do you recommend updating the code
um i think in general
uh slowly incrementally um
you know slowly incrementally one at a
time
if you can um sometimes it doesn't
really work because you've got to
upgrade things as a unit
but in many many cases what you want to
do is upgrade very slowly
and after every upgrade you run your
your carefully
uh your very thorough automated test
suite oh wait you say i don't have a
good automated test suite
well there's your problem go get
yourself an automated test suite okay
um it's not rocket science there's lots
of test frameworks
out there um and just you know pick a
test framework
write a bunch of tests um and you know
and
once you have some on automated test
suite now every time you can update you
re-run your test suite is it good is it
not good you up
run an update oh man everything broke
okay or maybe it doesn't you know maybe
it doesn't even compile
all right well at least you know what to
fix but you want to try to make each of
those changes as small as you can
and then use your automated test suites
to help make sure
that yeah it i mean it doesn't complain
immediately when i update
but does it really work and do what it's
supposed to do okay
an automated test suite lets you do
little tiny increments
update over and over and over again
package managers also
help you because they make it easy for
you to say see that
update to this version do it just one at
a time and typically you don't want to
update
you want to update incrementally not
just in terms of small number of
packages update
but small version increments if you're
using version one
and version 20 is out now
it's likely you might want to version
update that version to two to three to
four
or maybe one to five to eight to twelve
you know something like that okay
instead of just trying to do a big jump
one to twenty
okay um oftentimes projects
will do things like for example they'll
have backwards compatibility layers
and things that warn you hey wait a
minute you need to change it to this way
so
if you have to change something if you
change more slowly if you change the
version numbers in a more incremental
way
you're more likely to get help in
improving changing the software to be
ready for the current version and again
automated test suites the great thing
about an automated test me is once you
have one
those instead of saying man i got to
change it all at once because i don't
want to rerun my tests every time
we run your tests every time doesn't
automated okay
and then you greatly greatly reduce your
risks of
problems uh down the road um and
frankly you know um
i i guess this is probably obvious
anyway but i'll just say it
you know you may need to prioritize um
if you've got a lot of updates that have
stacked up
um some are probably more important than
others or easier than others
uh figure out what you want to
prioritize and prioritize those
okay um all right so i think that's
enough for that
all right i'm trying to understand how
open source software making money can
you help me understand this wasn't
really a frankly uh we could have a
whole
presentation on just that um in fact
the people have done whole long
presentations on just that
so um i'm not going to be able to answer
your question to give it full
justice but let me attempt to do a quick
answer
hopefully it will at least give you a
hand and then by all means uh seek out
um longer presentations that really
focus on that
all right so um
there's actually a lot of ways that
people make money and a lot of
in a lot of cases people are doing
developing open source software for
reasons other than
making money in the way that you're
thinking about it anyway
so let me start by answering the
question that's directly asked
okay how do people make money opens
their software well first of all
a lot of open source software projects
sell support
uh or companies sell support to it so
hey you can use the software for free
um and a lot of companies talk about in
terms of funnels
um you can't sell services if nobody
uses your products
so your first step is how the heck do
you get customers in the door
i'm gonna give them the product for free
okay or a low price
and and once they're using the software
are comfortable with it
oh wait a minute they want to use it do
it more with it um
sell support some companies um they have
like the
uh the core is open source and then
there are various at
editions that are proprietary closed
source that you can use but they charge
they'll charge extra for those um
another thing to be fair is that
although open source software is often
no cost
there's no requirement for that that's
not you'll notice in my definition
that wasn't part of the definition okay
so people have
and continue to sell open source
software
um now that assumes that you're trying
to make money
just like typical proprietary or closer
software vendors
but in fact a lot of folks this is
not the primary reason um for a lot of
organizations
um open participating in open source
software is
a money thing but it's not about making
money it's cost
avoidance you know if you hopefully
you're familiar with how profit is
calculated right
income versus minus outgo right um
so you know revenue minus expenses um so
basically if you if you can reduce what
you
spend you end up with more profit
in many many organizations use and
support
open source software because it's much
cheaper
than trying to develop the software
themselves
historically if you look back
you know starting from the late 60s
early 70s there were a number of
suppliers who were selling various
versions of unix
um and each of them you know would take
some software
modify try to sell and the reality was
that it turns out to be really really
costly to do that
but if you can take a vast amount of
open source software
um and either use it and use it directly
or use it to sell something else
or use it simply to support your
infrastructure it's a lot cheaper
than trying to build it all in house
even if you have the capabilities
um there's a um you know you there's a
lost opportunity if you use your
resources to do that
wait a minute here's some open source
software it's either does what we need
or it almost does what we need
and we can make some small improvements
and make it better and now we can use it
for our purposes
now once a organization makes an
improvement to open source offer they
have a decision to make
should they keep that improvement
in-house or should they try to release
it back
well you would you might think that oh
keeping it in-house is the obvious
solution but actually
no ninety percent of the costs of
software are actually in the sustain in
the maintenance process
not in the original development so for
most folks it's a lot
cheaper to get that improvement back
into the main open source software
project
because that means then they don't have
to keep figuring out how to maintain it
uh they don't have to keep trying to
figure out how to make that work with
other improvements that are being made
to that software over time and so
as a pure economic model it is much
cheaper for me reducing my expenses
okay to take open source software
improve it get those improvements back
to the project
and now i have something that is far
less expensive
than and possibly more functional
than what i might have done myself and
so
for many many folks it's not making
money it's a cost avoidance
and i should honestly note a third which
is
there are a lot of people who just like
to write software
it's fun and in a world where everybody
seems to think that the only thing
that's important in the world is making
money we sometimes forget that
you know what humans are humans and
humans are awesome
and humans like being creative and doing
things like
creating software um and we should be
grateful to those folks and celebrate
these folks because they make some of
the most
interesting and useful software in the
world so
those are three different and and we can
delve in
further but hopefully that at least
gives you an answer that question all
right many companies prefer to use or
reuse open
software don't want to share anyway in
this case how is the open source
software
how the i'm not sure in this case how
the open source software fundamental is
a
chief i don't okay i don't exactly
understand that question
so i'll answer what i think you meant
and we'll i'll hope i got it
all right um you know what this is
something called the free rider problem
um but the great thing from the open
source software world
is that you know what if somebody wants
to reuse take some open source software
and use it and contribute nothing back
it also costs the open source software
project nothing
and it turns out that a relatively small
percentage it depends on the software
but
typically maybe a percent one percent
maybe two or
of the of the people who use the
software
turn around and contribute that's okay
as long as you have a massive number of
users
so if you only have a hundred users and
only one percent
are provide any support back you only
have one person who's giving any help
that's a problem
if you have millions of people using
that software
this is not a problem okay the uh the
linux kernel is available for anybody to
use
not everybody supports back they
literally have
thousands of developers and they have an
incredible
uh release cadence same for kubernetes
so although it can be a problem as long
as you've got a vast number of users
the fact that many users don't
contribute back is okay as long as some
are willing to work with and contribute
back
and uh large numbers help a lot there
um should we take open source offer and
do changes for needs without disclosing
to the public ah
i kind of covered that earlier um
you can do that with any code believe it
or not you can even do that with gpl
code that is perfectly legal
whether or not it's wise to do that is a
different question
if your needs are so weird and peculiar
and no one else is
ever likely to do anything like that
maybe that's fine
um but um
while it's legal to do that that doesn't
make it
wise so let's talk about why you do that
first of all
if you're an academic you might say well
i changed the code but nobody would want
my use my ratty code it's not really
intended for production use
yes but you still should release it why
because we have a real problem in
science something called the
reproducibility crisis
there's an incredible amount of claims
that are claimed to be science
but in fact when people attempt to
reproduce the results
we find out that in fact they're not
true
okay and that's a big problem in science
today some areas of science much more
than
others so if you're an academic and you
want to make a claim
and your claim is somehow based on
software you should be releasing that
software
not because you think that the rest of
the world is going to
just use that as production code but so
that you can answer
exactly how you got the results what was
your analysis
modern academic papers just don't have
the space to record the details that are
necessary
um and there have been some serious
problems um
i there was actually a problem in 2001
where there's a major algorithmic
breakthrough uh in something called the
stat the satisfiability problem
um but for quite some time although
there was a paper that described this
algorithm breakthrough no one else could
reproduce the results
finally the code was made public and in
fact in this particular case it turns
out that the
it was true but the paper had failed
to make some important details clear
and really it's almost inevitable you
just can't make a paper
say everything by releasing the code
they release it now
what happens if it's production code
you're using in yours in your
environment
well you can but if you do that every
time that project makes an
update you're not going to have to
figure out how to merge
your improvements with theirs and they
didn't make their changes to work with
yours because they don't know what yours
are
very very quickly you end up paying an
incredible amount of time and effort
and money trying to take that code and
merge it with the other changes that
were made
and the more active that other open
source software project is
the harder and more expensive it is um
in general this is a real problem
whereas if you bring it back
you can avoid that 90 percent you know
that well
that huge cost of sustainment um and of
course
once companies start doing that once
individuals start doing that
um the project starts moving faster and
that becomes
even more important for other people to
contribute back to make sure that their
improvements get
in so while it's legal
that doesn't make it wise and you should
be
trying to make decisions that are wise
not just legal
okay all righty uh
let's see here i'm gonna go back to the
uh um
to the chat uh let's see here
um wow there are a lot of questions here
so let me attempt i have a limited time
but let me try to get to them
um david uh there is one question really
i think there are a couple of questions
uh the rest of them are thanking you for
the presentation
uh if i can orient you there is one
question from
gauche
okay cve json 5.0 schema
well i don't know who the wii is um i
mean
okay but i mean the cv process does it
project
process community whatever um you know
there is of course uh json 5.0
but we need more than that we need to do
a better job of
com of connecting the cve
reports to uh the software that's
vulnerable so
that that can be determined completely
automatically in almost all cases
um so i mean yes there's there's uh
various improvements to
as they update their json but in my mind
that's the more important
question um yeah she assumes the
developers can
center tennis ritchie well and to be
fair the problems that they had
at the time were quite different um you
know they were trying to make
very limited equipment do a whole lot
um you know modern phones
are thousands of times faster thousands
probably millions of times faster you
know thousands of times faster a
thousand times more memory
than the equipment that they were
working with initially so
um you know different circumstances uh
different problems um let's see here
yes the slides will become available um
okay no matter the language we do see
plenty more vulnerabilities in the
application stack where the lower stack
although the system background blast
radius
um i think that's kind of
over simplifying but there's some truth
to it
i think the re i would characterize it
slightly differently although
maybe it's a subtle distinction um the
system tier because
that's used by so many different
completely different applications
um gets a lot of focus from a lot of
different folks
and so um a number of vulnerabilities
get squished out from a number of the
system to your component simply because
there's more people using them than any
one specific application
stack um and of course a lot of the
application stack stuff moves
is faster moving and changing and when
you make a lot of changes
in a hurry you're more likely to make
mistakes i mean that's true for
software's just for anything else
but i think the reality is that we need
to worry about security at all letters
okay and there are basic fundamental
principles that apply no matter what you
need to know
i mean it's true that for example i
mentioned memory safety
for many many languages you know your
solution is use a language that provides
memory safety you're done
for some folks though you usually use a
memory a language that's usually memory
safe but you can disable them
limit when you disable them and when you
do now you gotta apply that knowledge
that's specific to memory safety
issues because in the unsafe parts it's
um you have to apply that of course if
you're preparing cnc plus plus
uh there is no safety it's always unsafe
and therefore
um you have to write with extra counter
make sure you don't have any of those
problems
but you know a vast amount of stuff is
just true across the board and you learn
it
all right uh okay humans are awesome
okay well
yeah yep fsf can you know you know what
the people who write the code
all the restaurants depend on you know
like any other infrastructure i'm always
i'm grateful to those many unsung heroes
who make our roads uh you know build the
build our buildings and oh yes write the
software that we all depend on
so i'm grateful to all of them including
many many of you who develop the
software that the rest of us depend on
but please please um there's some
um i've tried to kind of give that
surface
take a course i point it to a free one
um
you know i'll learn a little bit of you
you know if you're doing if you're
managing or involved in open source
projects
uh try to get badges uh get some uh
tools into your ci pipeline um
while it doesn't guarantee those things
don't guarantee everything
they really make a tremendous difference
all right um wow i'm out of
am i out of questions i can't believe
that surely people have some more
questions for me
because i do want to answer questions as
kind of the point of this
yeah you probably have time for maybe
one or two more more questions one or
two more questions
all right so uh somebody quickly uh type
in a question
so we will uh i can't believe i managed
to get through them all
there were some interesting there are a
number of interesting questions here
um okay
um i had
when i was creating this presentation i
had originally thought
about uh diving in for example
into the many different uh common kinds
of vulnerabilities um
you know i mentioned right here um but
um
i decided not to um there is always a
danger first of all the thinking that if
you know the most common kinds you know
all there is to know about security and
that's not true
um but uh in 45 minutes i just wouldn't
have had time
to get in enough um it's not that i need
a lot of time it's just 45 minutes
isn't quite enough um and so
you know what i really want you to do
and says point you do these top lists
pointing to a courses like the one i
just mentioned that kind of walk through
what are the top ones how do you counter
them but you know
counter them in terms of things like you
know write code this way instead of that
way or
use this kind of approach instead of
that a kind of approach
none of them are terribly complex
mentally particularly if you're just
worried on what am i trying to avoid and
how do i fix it i mean you don't need to
know the details
of memory management to know how to
avoid buffer overflows
you know don't try to read and write out
of the buffers
you usually arrays that that you're
supposed to be using
check make sure that you're within them
it's not complicated
at least mentally it can be complicated
to do because you have to keep doing it
over and over again but
if you're using c or c plus plus or any
other i'd say sponsor that's your pay
that's what you're paying for
you know you are getting all the control
but now you have to take responsibility
for the
um awesome level of control you receive
if that's not if you're not comfortable
with that
if that's not what you wanted maybe
these these were
not the right design decisions for what
you have planned
um if i if you use c
uh what tools or guidance lines exist to
assist uh gbd and center
well in fact i've already gone through a
number of those there are a number of
guidelines for
um i i talk through the course there's a
cumber um it lists a number of common
vulnerabilities
um when you when i talk in the course
itself mentions specific things so
you know don't for c don't use stir copy
if you don't have to
uh using stern copy or s and printf
or some other function like that which
provides automated protection is going
to
basically replace the dangerous ones
with the less dangerous ones
and the course goes through the video
instead of this function do this or that
you know
consider using this instead gdb is not
really going to be
so much of your friend here gdb can help
you find if you
have a particular input that you know is
a problem but the challenge is finding
the inputs
fuzzers can sometimes help you find
inputs that will cause trouble
in which case once if you use a fuzzer
and it finds a vulnerability
then yeah you could use gdb to help you
find those
but it's much better to know ahead of
time where the common problems
you know what kinds of function calls or
approaches should i use instead
and then using tools to detect problems
um and fixing those remaining problems
is really the
the way to go if you're using if you're
using c i know you see a lot myself so
it's not like you can't write secure
software in c
you just gotta be stinking careful if
you're writing in c
also go read the standards if you have
not read the standard
in particular the appendix on what on
undefined uh
behavior you gotta do it there's a lot
of things that
are undefined that a lot of people who
write and see have
no idea and they're just basically foot
guns waiting for you
so hopefully that answers that question
david gcc seemed to be
including some of the um cwu deduction
lately with their f analyzer option um
that i'm finding useful to run through
right now right now as far as i'm
concerned
it's just uh gcc and c lang also has
some tools
you know using gcc and c lang to detect
some vulnerabilities
it's a tool it's just like your other
tools turn on as many as you can
by all means turn on the mechanisms in
gcc
to detect vulnerabilities on the other
hand don't expect that gcc
or c lang or any other tool will find
all the vulnerabilities
you want to learn how to avoid them in
the first place and then you want to use
tools
to help you find the ones that got
through
right absolutely thank you very good
very good well done yes you did it
we are right at time everyone um big
thank you to david
and toshua for their time today and
thank you all for
participating and asking questions um as
a reminder this recording will be on the
linux foundation youtube page later
today
and a copy of the presentation slides
will be added to
the lenox foundation website uh we hope
you all
join us for some future mentorship
sessions and
that's a wrap have a wonderful day
everybody
thank you so much everyone